so the first thing i want to say to you
is that i'm sorry
i am so sorry that you have to grow up
in a
world where this is still present that
was meghan markle addressing
the state of our country last week in a
video message to the graduating class at
her alma mater immaculate heart
i know you know that black lives matter
now e.t is learning that megan isn't
just talking
she's taking action the black lives
matters movement
matters to megan and it matters to harry
and i understand that this is going to
be
an area where we're going to see the
couple doing a lot more work and taking
a lot more interest
[Music]
people across the world have been
protesting against police brutality
following george floyd's death a
46-year-old minnesota man
who died on may 25th after a police
officer pressed his knee
into his neck for more than eight
minutes
george floyd's life mattered and brianna
taylor's life mattered and philando
castile's life mattered and tamir rice's
life mattered
and so did so many other people whose
names we know and whose names we do not
know
royal expert katie nicole tells et
meghan and hubby prince harry are
getting involved in the blm movement
here's how they're speaking to community
leaders and from a number of different
organizations and charities
i'm told this is something they want to
keep private at the moment
while they work out what they can do and
how they can help and we will over the
coming days and weeks
see a shift from their covert efforts to
this
black lives matters and what they're
doing within the black community where
they are
and how they're trying to help these
people i want you to know that for me
i am here with you as a mother as a wife
as a woman as a woman of color and as
your sister
[Applause]
that was megan addressing the topic of
race during the couple's 10-day tour of
africa
last fall she also spoke about her own
experience with racism
in this recently resurfaced psa from
2012.
some of the slurs that i've heard or the
really
offensive jokes or the names it's just
hit me in a really strong way and then
you know a couple years ago i heard
someone call my mom the n-word
this is something that megan
particularly is very passionate about
and she feels that having spoken out
about race about um racial equality
she sees herself as a role model she
believes that there is an expectation on
her
to address what's going on and to
support and that is what they're doing
i wasn't sure what i could say to you i
wanted to say the right thing
and i was really nervous that i i
wouldn't or that it would get picked
apart and i realized
the only wrong thing to say is to say
nothing
[Music]